welcome back everybody today we're going
to use an all-purpose plow from dirt dog
on a 10 25 r we're going to keep it
going with the spring tilling for some
seed prep later this year going to help
with the
the preparation for the screening plot
that we're going to put in
along kind of the perimeter so we used a
ripper previously the ground was a
little bit too frozen i think we're
probably close to a month beyond that
date now we've had plenty of warm
temperatures i don't think we'll have an
issue and now this is not going to go
down into the earth as far as that
ripper or that subsoiler would do so i
don't think we're gonna have as big of
an issue i've never used one of these
before i've always kind of been a tiller
guy right but i'm trying to branch out
try some new things give it a shot see
how it works as always we're sponsored
by borah wheel spacers they are made in
america have a lifetime warranty if your
tractor feels tippy side to side
especially if you have a cab on it then
adding a set of wheel spacers can make a
big difference get more information on
them at the link down below now dirt dog
makes these apps all-purpose plows in
various sizes so this is
a smaller one about four foot wide maybe
my hair over that but it's going to be
three shanks or three rippers they're
all spring loaded too so as you're going
along it's going to have some give to it
some flexibility so if you hit a a rock
or a root or something else or just have
some resistance it's going to it's going
to kind of give and go over top of it a
little bit and come back down i think
we'll probably have to do multiple
passes now i'm excited to play around
with it see how it works you can see
this is quick hitch compatible you can
also hook it up directly to a category
one three-point hitch we are a dirt dog
dealer we sell and ship all over the
country this is a made in america
product so if you're looking for
something pretty affordable to cultivate
or till up prepare your earth this could
be a good option for you to consider oh
yeah and one last thing
dirt dog does recommend seven horsepower
per shank so three shanks here 21
horsepower off the top of my head i
can't remember if that is engine
horsepower or pto horsepower this is not
using a pto so i would tend to think
they're referencing engine horsepower so
we should be just fine
i can't envision this having a problem
but i guess we'll find out soon enough
hey really quick not to interrupt but
this is part one of a two-part video all
right we're gonna compare the results of
an all-purpose plow versus a tiller
let you make your own decision on what
works best what has the best finished
results we're going to use a subcompact
tractor a 1025r so this could apply to
any tractor out there but we're talking
about the sub compacts right now there
are attachments out there sized
appropriately for small tractors medium
tractors big tractors you name it so
make sure you're subscribed to see part
number two
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so we're part way through i
have a down and back and a down and back
so four passes total but we're going to
go over it again
kind of figuring this thing out thought
it was going to be just to drop it down
and go uh right out of the gate but
started hitting a few roots and it would
actually bog this thing right down its
track so you do have to feather that
three point depending on your terrain a
little bit up and down
when it would really hang up and i'd be
sitting there spinning if i let let go
of the throttle let my foot off the gas
it would actually these spring loaded
ties would actually slightly pull the
machine backwards it was kind of funny
other than that
it's a piece of cake you know so just
keep your hand on that that three point
or maybe
don't go down all the way just go down
part way something like that and you're
gonna be okay
this is what it looks like with one pass
it doesn't well there's a lot of until
ground in between where those furrows
are at so we're going to go through and
try to dissect the difference there
maybe one additional pass can get it
done
it could take multiple passes i don't
know but this isn't very hard this took
maybe 10 or 15 minutes to go
down and back a couple times really easy
to do nice day to do it we're learning
as we go
[Music]
[Applause]
now you guys may have noticed this sweet
looking canopy right up above me and
this is a rhino hide canopy all right mr
don mccoy founded this company and my
brother and i were privileged enough to
be able to purchase this from him at the
beginning of the year so now
rhino height is something that we can
sell you directly now this canopy is
unique for several reasons number one
it's very lightweight all right so this
is a one person job to take it on to
take it off you have a couple of wing
nuts here that you just loosen up you
can slide it right off so if you want to
take it down the road if you want to put
it in your garage it's easy enough to do
with one person all right it weighs how
much does it weigh
yeah it weighs 15 pounds so it's very
lightweight but rhino hide that name
suggests something this thing is tough
as nails i'm telling you we drove over
it with a
5000 series tractor so that thing
weighed over 10 000 pounds don has shot
this thing with a shotgun uh we dropped
40 or 70 pound weights on this thing it
didn't break this thing is meant to be
indestructible all right that's a
downside of a lot of canopies they're
big and bulky they're heavy and they're
going to get damaged if you hit a tree
limb or a tree branch or something else
so this is meant to solve all those pain
points it's made out of similar to that
bed liner type material like a drop in
bed liner in your truck so if you know
what that is you know those things can
take a beating so can this
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
okay lessons learned from pass number
two
this first one i'm a little bit
embarrassed about and i kind of let you
guys down at some point four wheel drive
early on i think disengaged so i was in
two wheel drive and i think that's why i
was spinning
my wheels literally i wasn't even paying
attention to the front wheels not
spinning but
just on the way back down and back on
the second pass the first time back i
noticed the front wheels weren't
spinning i was like what that's going on
i disengaged the four wheel drive
somehow so i re-engaged that that seemed
to make a world of difference being able
to put that plow deeper and just carry
on a lot easier but this is a very rough
ride that's what i'm finding out very
hard to stay
on line where i want to go the first
pass was easy the second pass was very
challenging with all these big clods all
around
who knows maybe the third pass will be a
little bit easier as it kind of breaks
them up a little bit i don't know but i
gotta try to get in between these rows
and that's been a challenge hopefully
this third pass knocks it out
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
all right so third pass
three more observations for you number
one this ride does not get easier that
was like riding the broken buck there
for a while
it just constantly wants to go back into
the same furrows that have already been
created so it's very hard to try to keep
it aligned and and dig up more earth
i found it was easier i was trying to
use the outside of the of the tire to
line up with this outside
tine but i found it easier to use the
center line of the hood to try to stay
in the middle of a row instead and then
match up with the center tine here the
third observation is actually i didn't
bottom out in my seat once and i noticed
it late in the third pass and i had
forgot
i had this little air bladder thing that
i put in here a little
um inflatable shim it is and i put that
in here and it's really helped prevent
bottoming out completely on this seat
and it kind of just sprung into my head
that was the reason why because i was
hitting some major bumps this whole time
this whole machine was rocking and
rolling
that was a pretty uncomfortable
experience after the first pass and we
don't have a lot of big boulders here
there's a lot of smaller rocks that are
strewn throughout and this was an
overgrown field that had a lot of
automotive and other things in it too so
i think we're hitting some routes there
but this is pretty easy conditions to
work in overall now i can't say this is
my number one tool pardon me wants to go
grab a tiller and just make a pass right
next to it to see how it looks
but maybe we'll do that in another video
now i don't want to make it seem like
it's all bad i mean it's a decent tool
it's cheaper than a tiller there's less
moving parts there's no gear box pto
shaft anything like that it's a lighter
piece of equipment so i mean overall you
can see the results here this is what my
grandpa's fields used to look like
every year it seemed like so this will
work but i just think personally a
tiller does a lot better job with just
one tool where we've tilled virgin
ground all over out here in just one
pass or even a second pass and it's just
a completely level even
consistent seed bed that's prepped and
ready to go without doing anything else
this just doesn't quite hold a candle to
it so anyway if you are looking for
something to help till up your ground
whether it's a plow a disc a tiller
we're happy to help we sell and ship all
over the country check out
goodworkstractors.com and if you enjoyed
today's video we'd love to have you tag
along hit that subscribe button right
down below i want to thank you for
taking time out of your day to stop by
and until next time stay safe we'll see
you soon
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]